if you're in our audience you know that
I've been covering the Trump Russia
story on the program for a while I've
covered events related to Russian
interference in the 2016 election
possible coordination between Russia and
members of the Trump administration it's
news it's worth discussing on a program
that deals with American politics and
I've made every effort to cover it in a
way that doesn't make unreasonable
assumptions or where I act like I know
things that we just don't yet know in
other words I try to make clear what is
fact what is speculation and what is
circumstantial and if you watch the show
you know that for a long time I've been
getting emails from a contingent of the
audience that questions a range of the
topics that relate to Trump and Russia
what's my justification for believing
this what do I think about that so I
thought it would be good to sort of sort
through and do a rundown of the facts
regarding everything Trump Russia and
how all of this informs my outlook on
the entire story this is more or less a
response to people who deny certain
indisputable facts but also people who
say that certain speculations are
totally baseless so let's start by
laying out four things that I solidly
believe to be true number one Russia
interfered in our election in 2016 that
is undeniable whether they flipped the
results is another story number two
there are some currently known facts
directly supporting the notion that
there was collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia certain facts
already definitively tell us this for
sure but the evidence is limited at this
time number three given an entire array
of other facts about countless other
matters any reasonable person should be
able to admit at this point that it
would be miraculous if there turned out
to be no other coordination between the
Russian government and the Trump
campaign in addition to what we already
know and number four and this might be
the most important point denialism about
Trump Russia by default should be put on
hold until the investigations have
concluded and the findings of gone
public journalists of
members of the public don't have the
legal authority that Congress the FBI
and other intelligence agencies have to
dig for evidence we can very reasonably
assume that there is a ton of deeply
relevant knowledge about all of this
that's just not in the hands of the
public yet and claims that there was no
collusion or that there is no evidence
of collusion or meaningless as long as
all that information is still behind
closed doors and by the same token no
one should make definitive pointed
claims about there being collusion yet
either in the context that there is not
yet enough evidence all I can do is talk
about what we know and give what I
believe to be justified interpretations
of each piece of the puzzle so let's
start with what we know
starting with Russian interference in
the 2016 presidential election amazingly
there are somehow still some people who
deny or have doubts that Russia even
interfered in the election at all
including our president but there are
some pretty obvious reasons why Trump
wouldn't want to admit any of it so
let's start by recreating that timeline
in September of 2015 the FBI called the
DNC to tell them that their servers had
been compromised by hackers affiliated
with the Russian government and the FBI
said it was the same group of Kremlin
connected hackers who had for years been
hacking the White House and State
Department and the DNC basically blew
off the warning in April of 2016 the
server attacks became more apparent to
the DNC and their top officials were
alerted for the first time and they
hired private independent cybersecurity
firm CrowdStrike to investigate who also
independently determined that the DNC
was attacked by hackers affiliated with
the Russian government in June of 2016
the DNC told the public they were hacked
by the Russian government and the next
day an anonymous person online calling
themself
gute referred to point O came forward
and said now CrowdStrike is wrong it
wasn't Russia who hacked the DNC it was
me and I'm just a random Romanian guy
with no connection to Russia I hacked
the DNC to expose the Illuminati gucchy
fur also posted authentic DNC documents
which proves that gucchy fur at some
point had access to DNC servers or
affiliated with someone that did and
cybersecurity experts in US Intel have
said that Gucci fur was likely a false
flag created by Russian intelligence to
deflect blame and this wouldn't be the
first time that Russia has created a
fake loan hacker to divert blame for
their hacks and Gucci fur discredited
themself in a number of ways which
supports the notion that Gucci fur is
acting on behalf of the Russian
government there is reasonable
justification for assuming that Gucci
fur is a Russian invention but even if
Gucci fur is Romanian and it happened
that Gucci fur was inside the DNC's
computer systems at the same time as the
Russians gucci furs identity doesn't
change the conclusions of the US
intelligence and several private
cybersecurity firms
that the DNC was also hacked by cozy
bear and fancy bear to hacking groups
known to be tied to the Kremlin and
famous for hacking Russia's adversaries
so back to the timeline over the course
of June 2016 crowd strikes conclusions
that the DNC was hacked by those two
Russian groups are corroborated by other
private independent cybersecurity firms
including threat Kinect SecureWorks and
Fidelis cybersecurity July of 2016 three
days before the start of the Democratic
National Convention
WikiLeaks publishes tens of thousands of
hack DNC emails gucchy first said this
was going to happen the emails humiliate
the Clinton campaign humiliate the DNC
and lead to the resignation of the DNC's
chair CEO CFO and communications
director it is clear that those who were
responsible for this were only
interested in making the DNC look bad
and hurting Hillary Clinton's chances of
winning the election Julian Assange has
denied that Russia was his source for
leaks but Asajj might not even know who
gave him the documents and let's keep in
mind that Assange used to have his own
TV show on russian outlet RT and we know
that Assange has long disliked Hillary
Clinton and Assange was recently caught
haphazardly offering opposition research
on a Democratic US senator to someone
who was
to be Sean Hannity on Twitter so it's no
secret that both Russia and Julian
Assange have it out for the Democratic
Party in October of 2016 the Department
of Homeland Security and the Office of
the Director of National Defense
released a joint statement the US
intelligence community is confident that
the Russian government directed the
recent compromises of emails from US
persons and institutions including from
US political organizations we believe
based on the scope and sensitivity of
these efforts that only Russia's senior
most officials could have authorized
these activities next month in November
two days before Election Day thousands
of more hacked DNC emails were published
and clearly whoever coordinated the
hacking and the publishing of the DNC
emails chose to time things out in a way
that would be most damaging to the
Democratic Party and the Clinton
campaign also in November of 2016 NSA
director and commander of the US Cyber
Command Mike Rogers blame the Russian
government and attributes motive quote
there shouldn't be any doubt in anyone's
mind this was a conscious effort by a
nation-state to attempt to achieve a
specific effect in December of 2016 the
CIA tells the Senate that it's quite
clear that people connected to the
Kremlin hack the DNC and interfered with
the 2016 election specifically with the
purpose of helping Donald Trump win a
week later u.s. and foreign intelligence
officials tell ABC News that Putin was
personally involved in the DNC hacks and
other efforts to interfere with the 2016
election these anonymous US and foreign
officials say that they were directly
involved in tracking the hacks January 6
2017 the CIA FBI and Office of the
Director of National Intelligence
release a joint public statement saying
they've concluded with high confidence
that the Russian government hack DNC
emails and published them through
WikiLeaks with the goal of helping Trump
get elected and that all of this was
directly ordered by Vladimir Putin in
February of this year Trump's
Secretary of State tacitly admitted that
Russia interfered in the 2016 election
by hacking so you can't just say oh it's
all Obama's Intel people who are
manufacturing hysteria around Russian
hacking it wasn't just Obama appointed
people in Intel making these claims
before this anyway and also in February
of this year Jeanette Mann freh who's
the head of cyber security at DHS
confirmed that not only did Russia
target voting systems in 21 states which
we already knew but that Russia
succeeded in at least some of those
instances she said that these hacks no
doubt came from the Russian government
Russia also recruited an army of trolls
and BOTS to influence public opinion via
social media which is supported by a
mountain of academic research journalism
testimony in Congress and criminal
indictments that's probably the least
controversial truth in all of this so
I'm not even going to waste more time on
that Russia is well known for hacking
and otherwise trying to interfere with
the affairs of adversarial government's
political parties and elections
why wouldn't they try to do this here in
the US and 2016 in order to help a
presidential candidate that has been
conspicuously sympathetic to Russian
interests at every stage of the election
you can say I'm a shill for the
Democratic Party or a shill for
corporate media or whatever other
nonsense you want to say many of the
people who say those things about me may
not be aware that I am constantly
extremely critical of the DNC and the
Democratic Party on this program I do
not defend the DNC in their corruption
I don't defend what was found in their
leaked emails or their treatment of
Bernie Sanders during the election I
come to you as someone without a dog in
this fight as someone who doesn't pull
punches when it comes to Democrats in
the DNC and I will be the first to admit
that outlets like MSNBC and The
Huffington Post maybe are guilty of some
of that but what we've got to understand
is that many Bernie Sanders supporters
have a grudge against the DNC for their
treatment
Berni so they want to believe that the
email leaks were righteous and
coordinated by good-faith actors I'm a
Bernie supporter with some of those same
grudges but I'm not gonna let that blind
me from what the evidence points to
which is that Russia was responsible for
hacking and leaking the DNC documents
and emails and totally understandably
many Trump fans also don't want to
believe Russia hack the DNC because they
don't want to believe that Trump had an
unfair advantage in the election and
they definitely don't want to believe
that the Trump campaign may have had
knowledge or involvement with Russian
interference in the election a plot by
the US intelligence community and the
private cybersecurity industry and the
press to falsely blame the hacks on
Russia would be a much bigger and far
less believable conspiracy than Russians
hacking Democrats both Democratic and
Republican members of Congress agree
that Russia hacked the DNC and
influenced the election in other ways
Republicans want to deny almost
everything about Trump Russia but
they've had a lot of trouble denying
that no one can ignore what motivations
Russia would have for doing this no one
can ignore Russia's horrible
relationship with the Obama
administration and regardless of whether
there was Trump Russia collusion it's
impossible to deny that Trump implicitly
and explicitly was going to be a more
Pro Russia president than Hillary
Clinton and Russia is almost certainly
very interested in making the u.s. look
stupid to the world which by the way has
been another result of Trump's victory
and Russia succeeded in making our
electoral process seem vulnerable and
disordered they had every reason to try
to tip the election in trumps favor
because it was a win win win for Russia
as far as collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government like
I said very little is known right now
but we have to reserve most of our
judgments for when the facts come out
facts that at this point in time are in
the possession only of the Justice
Department and the congressional
intelligence committees here's one
instance
of apparent collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government that
we know about at least an attempt at
collusion June 9th of 2016 Donald Trump
jr. Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort
literally the head of the campaign met
with a Kremlin connected Russian lawyer
for the purpose of receiving dirt on
Hillary Clinton before the meeting Trump
jr. was informed via email that this
dirt was part of a Kremlin plot to help
Donald Trump less than a week earlier
Trump jr. received an email from an
intermediary representing a senior
Russian government official and Trump
jr. knew he was talking to someone
representing the Russian government the
email to Trump jr. said in part quote
this would incriminate Hillary and her
dealings with Russia and would be very
useful to your father
this is obviously very high-level and
sensitive information but as part of
Russia and its government support for
mr. Trump Donald Trump's jr. response
was if it's what you say I love it
especially later in the summer the
intermediary wrote back to set up Trump
juniors meeting with a Russian attorney
the Russian attorney Natalya Veselin
that skaia is well known for her work on
behalf of the Russian government to
advocate for the lifting of US sanctions
on Russia the Trump team and the Russian
lawyer did not just sit around talking
about the weather that day and long
after the fact Donald Trump jr. was
caught lying about the meeting not only
is this attempted collusion with the
Russian government but it might violate
federal law which states a foreign
national shall not directly or
indirectly make a contribution or a
donation of money or another thing of
value or expressly or impliedly promised
to make a contribution or a donation in
connection with any federal state or
local election it shall be unlawful for
a person to solicit accept or receive a
thing of value from a foreign national
and by the way this is just totally
secondary Steve Bannon later said that
the chances of those Trump campaign
officials not introducing the
representatives from russia to trump
while they were in Trump Tower are zero
and when I say that this was a 10
did collusion I'm not saying for sure
that it was only an attempt but I'm
saying it was at minimum an attempt the
Trump team could have been very
successful in colluding with Russia that
day but all we know for certain is that
there was an attempt and you can write
this off as no big deal but 90% of what
matters in this particular situation is
intent so let's talk about people
associated with the Trump campaign you
have to be naive to dismiss what we know
about the president's associates the
people that he and his campaign chose to
become involved with and their
connections to Russia their criminal
histories in some cases their blatant
desperate attempts to lie about and
cover up their dealings with the
Russians both during and after the
campaign Michael Flynn by the time he
was hired as a top adviser to the Trump
campaign was already known for his close
ties to the Russian government and had
been criticized for it by people from
all over the political spectrum when
illegally lied to the US government
about money he had received from the
Russian government Flynn spoke to
Russian ambassador kis lyac several
times during the Trump transition and
lied about it one of those calls was on
the same day the Obama administration
announced sanctions on Russia and Flynn
was forced to basically admit that US
sanctions were discussed during the call
Jared Kushner during the Trump
transition discussed with Russian
ambassador kis lyac the possibility of
using a Russian consulate to set up a
secret and secure communications channel
between the Trump team and the Kremlin
in order to hide their conversations
from American intelligence this was at a
meeting between Kushner and kis lyac at
the beginning of December of 2016 at
Trump Tower Jared Kushner has also lied
to the US government about meetings he
had with Russians Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort has a long history of both
criminal activity and loyalty to Russia
from oh six 209 he was paid ten million
dollars a year by Putin oligarch Oleg
Deripaska to secretly help influence
politics media and business in the US
and Europe to benefit
Russia and for nearly a decade mana fort
was paid to manipulate Ukrainian
politics to benefit Russia which
involved receiving laundered Ukrainian
tax dollars stolen by pro-russian
politicians in Ukraine mana fort
currently faces federal charges in the
u.s. including conspiracy against the
United States money-laundering not
registering as a foreign agent and lying
to the FBI because of intercepted
communications and payments from Russia
during the Trump transition mana Ford
has been under investigation
for the past year by several US
intelligence and law enforcement
agencies and was the subject of FBI
wiretaps before during and after the
2016 election two weeks before the
Republican National Convention mana Ford
offered private briefings on the
election to Putin oligarch Oleg
Deripaska mana Ford said in the email if
he needs private briefings we can
accommodate and again this is another
example of what we have to wait and find
out about before we go dismissing these
emails are among tens of thousands of
communications and documents that the
FBI has that the public does not but
mana Ford is a confirmed person of
interest in the do J's Trump Russia
investigation Trump campaign advisor
Michael Caputo had previously worked on
a Russian propaganda campaign in the
u.s. to improve Russia's image among
Americans Trump campaign adviser Jeff
Sessions had to recuse himself from his
own Trump Russia investigation after it
was discovered that he lied about
meetings he had with Russia's ambassador
to the u.s. Trump campaign advisor
Carter page has a long history with the
Russian government and is also under FBI
investigation and he's known among his
peers as an outspoken critic of US
foreign policy and a strong Putin
sympathizer Paige has been known for
making public comments in Russia
criticizing the US and praising Putin a
US diplomat to Russia who knew Paige
said that he has always been a brazen
apologist for anything Moscow did from
Oh for 207 he worked in Moscow as a
banker and as a consultant to an
energy company owned by the Russian
government and in 2013 he helped Russian
spies in New York City gather
information about sanctions and energy
plans in July of 2016 during the
election Page went to Moscow to meet
with Russian officials and the Trump
campaign including Jeff Sessions were
aware of this trip before and after it
took place for the year and a half that
followed page in the Trump campaign lied
saying the meeting never happened
including Jeff sessions who lied about
it to the US Senate also in July of 2016
page met with Russian ambassador Sergey
kis lyac and lied about that as well
Trump campaign advisor Sam Nunn Berg has
confirmed that Trump campaign advisor
Carter page was colluding with the
Russian government and he believes that
the Justice Department has russia
evidence against trump specifically
george papadapolis was a trump campaign
advisor who one campaign official said
interacted with the Trump campaign
constantly in March of 2016
Trump identified Papadopoulos as a
campaign adviser and said he's an
excellent guy Papadopoulos stayed
influential throughout the election and
was even responsible for setting up
meetings for Donald Trump with world
leaders in April of 2016 Papadopoulos
had a meeting with a Kremlin middleman
who told Papadopoulos that the Russian
government had dirt on Hillary Clinton
including thousands of emails in January
of 2017 Papadopoulos lied to the FBI
about his meetings with Russians and
then immediately tried to delete all of
his emails he had with Russians he since
pled guilty to lying to the FBI and is
now cooperating with Robert Muller's
investigation at the very very least the
Trump campaign was filled with criminals
people tied up in Russian interests and
people who were constantly having
meetings with the Russians and lying
about it all the time in January of this
year a member of the House Intelligence
Committee x' trump russia investigation
said that members of the trump
administration committed crimes during
the 2016 campaign in February of this
year another member of that committee
said that they have quote an abundance
of evidence that there was Trump Russia
collusion during the campaign and as
aras the Department of Justice's
investigation you might be saying oh the
investigations corrupt the FBI and
Muller are corrupt what about the new
Ness memo the newness memo to trump
didn't change anything it didn't prove
that the Steele dossier was an important
part of the FISA applications against
Carter page never mind the fact that
more and more of the dossier has been
proven to be true
the new Ness memo made a lot of other
unproven assertions Nunez didn't even
see the documents he wrote about in the
memo there's nothing that proves the FBI
acted improperly at any point the FBI
said the memo was bogus
and the Democratic memo refuted every
single thing in the new Ness memo which
essentially gets us back to square one
in terms of knowing who to believe the
point of all this some of what I've
discussed here is evidence of collusion
or at least facts that strongly support
the notion that there was collusion and
some of it is circumstantial but
important to keep in mind for the time
being but what the knee-jerk Trump
Russia deniers are demanding as further
evidence of collusion would only come
out in court proceedings which have not
yet happened
most of these conversations about
whether or not there was collusion
simply need to be put on hold until the
investigation is over another thing to
keep in mind is that Trump himself did
not necessarily need to be personally
involved with Russian actors or even
need to be involved with conversations
with staffers about coordinating with
Russia for there to have been collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia if
you're a member of the Trump campaign
and you're coordinating with Russia to
get dirt on Hillary or to promise things
to the Kremlin in exchange for election
interference most likely the last thing
you're going to do is keep trouble
himself updated for a number of reasons
mostly because it wouldn't be necessary
and it would be sort of stupid to
legally implicate your candidate and the
soon-to-be President Trump Russia
collusion is not defined by Trump
himself plotting participating in or
even having knowledge of the collusion
and setting this burden of proof is
unnecessary and it's often done so
disingenuous
Trump has proven to merely be a
figurehead when it comes to policy and
when it comes to rhetoric he's not a
real thinker or a mover why wouldn't the
exact same circumstances apply to
collusion
I'm not even denying that the potential
collusion could have been very
low-budget and improvisational I've
never claimed that this was all part of
some grand scheme that started 20 years
ago where the Kremlin has been planning
for decades to install Donald Trump to
serve their interests I'm not even
saying that if there was collusion the
Kremlin had to have been plotting as far
back as even 2014 that's probably not
what would have happened that's the
caricature of what collusion would look
like that's the straw man but you have
to ask yourself why would Russia go to
such lengths to help a candidate that
would do nothing for them the Russian
government would not do all of this
unless they felt certain that it would
be in Russia's interest and why does
Trump feel so obligated to stay loyal to
the Russians when it comes to Russia
Trump has constantly praised Putin
refused to implement US sanctions on
Russia refused to admit the obvious fact
that Russia infiltrated the American
electoral process the list goes on what
we know is that Russia wanted to tip the
election in trumps favor
we know that the Trump campaign was
aware of at least that as early as June
of 2016 and many Trump campaign
associates had private meetings with
Russian officials or people tied to the
Kremlin which they lied about and we
only know about the meetings that have
so far been uncovered that's what we
know what we don't know is pretty much
everything that's the key point here we
know all of this and it's all very shady
but in the bigger picture we still know
almost nothing only the people
participating in the investigations know
anything even if we ignore the multiple
congressmen involved with the house
investigation who came out and said
we've seen evidence of crimes and
collusion even if we ignore the ties
between Russia and the Trump team
members and all of the lies and all of
the indictments we have to acknowledge
that we are currently only in
middle of this saga and no one knows
what will happen because basically
nothing much has even had the chance to
happen yet the Trump Whitehouse and
Trump supporters and other Trump Russia
deniers say oh well we don't have
anything something would have happened
by now
so Trump Russia is nothing other than
hysteria it's not true this is meant to
be an extremely slow process it has to
be in order to be effective
investigations like these often take
years and the people conducting these
investigations are intentionally and
carefully keeping the details of what
they're learning under wraps we're just
going to have to wait to find out but in
the meantime yes we should not make
hasty accusations regarding specific
circumstances and situations but it
would also make absolutely no rational
sense to assume that there's nothing to
the story given what we already know and
given that the investigations have not
yet even had the opportunity to tell us
what actually happened